workers at this nutritional supplement
plant raised to meet orders but no
matter how hard they work they can only
meet 15% of customer demands because the
plant lacks the capacity to handle large
orders young entrepreneurs like komlin
bazaar I could strain by a lack of funds
and government support our diverse
implement dear Mandy oh grandma we want
the government to act on two parameters
to create a bank to support young
entrepreneurs and to invest more in
skilled youth instead of wasting
resources trying to appease every
unemployed person this way the skilled
individuals can set up businesses to
employ young people but reviving the
economy is not the only concern for
Togolese in this election in rural areas
where most of the population lives about
60% of the people like access to
electricity and clean water
- you mentioned that our poverty there's
widespread poverty among the population
there is little or no economic
empowerment for the poor some voters
want to change to the current regime to
them it will mean economic freedom Togo
is rich and as the president himself
acknowledged resources are currently
controlled by a few individuals this is
unacceptable
campaign rallies are underway as
political parties try to convince the
voters to support their candidates
members of the assembly family have been
in power here since 1967
many - police aren't sure if changing
the younger assembly will make any
difference but president phony assembly
supporters believe he provides the
security and stability that Togo needs
but the opposition is says only it can
grow the economy and bring prosperity to
toggle but many voters are less
confident of a quick fix to the economy
and their living conditions larger
vapors would be I'm not going to vote
because I can't go and cue up the
Catholic ballot for a change that never
comes but when I know my vote will make
a difference maybe I'll change my mind
for now she's passing up the thrill of
casting her first ballot and like her
many others think
the politicians are out of tune for
their needs how many trees al-jazeera
know me